en compagnie de guy bobino où irène
chagnaud propose voyage sans passeport
libre opinion nous avons eu le plaisir
de voyager plusieurs fois en votre
compagnie et aujourd'hui vous allez nous
faire connaître un visage un peu
particulier de rio n'est ce pas je vais
essayer de ne pas trop parler de la plus
belles baies du monde ni du pain de
sucre bien que bien quand ils vont en ce
moment mais l'une des choses les plus
des phares hantée qui saisit le visiteur
dès son arrivée à rioz c'est la
circulation elle est en hausse et
terrible écouter jeu sans faire un cours
de géographie
vous savez que rio environ deux millions
cinq cent mille habitants et que c'est
une ville construite d'une façon
extrêmement fantaisiste au milieu d'une
multitude de collines d'inaccessible
alors dans le centre de rio se trouve le
ministère les grosses entreprises les
agences de navigation les banques les
journaux etc et la population elle même
est obligés de loger ailleurs en dehors
bien entendu comme elle se rend à son
travail chaque jour
c'est là commence le problème est
l'explication de la quantité
invraisemblable de moyens de transport
qui existe dans rio oui on se croirait
presque place de l'opéra c'est à peu
près ça c'est la rue principale norme
chasser la rue principale oui je dois
vous dire que la banlieue c'est pour
certains de l'autre côté de la baie de
guanabara et même dans la baie également
qu'il ne comprend pas moins d'une
centaine d'îles aussi le marché
le grand marché qui correspond à noël
centrale et sur le bord de l'eau et
provoquent un va et vient continuel de
bateaux de toutes tailles pour
transporter les marchandises
ouais
là
également des bateaux bien entendu pour
amener dans le centre des affaires les
employés ouvriers hommes d'affaires qui
habite de l'autre côté
je crois que le premier souci du
monsieur qui débarque que là-bas et
d'aller acheter son journal est un
journal beaucoup plus épais que ce que
nous avons et qui attache beaucoup plus
d'importance au football vos affaires du
moyen-orient
foule est dense mais typiquement mais
presque entièrement masculine
pourquoi mais les femmes ne travaillent
pas autant que si écoutez je ne
répondrai que difficilement à cette
question je suppose que elles doivent
travailler mes temps plus tard si vous
voulez ou alors c'est l'idéal les hommes
travaillaient les femmes restent à la
maison c'est peut-être ça tout le monde
s'empresse de trouver un moyen de
transport est alors les autobus ça vous
avez le choix de tous les âges et de
toutes les tailles alors il ya une chose
particulière pour les autobus are you
c'est que plus ils sont petits plus ils
vont vite et je crois que le miracle de
rios et qu'il reste encore quelques
piétons et pour arranger la circulation
en a maintenu les tramways alors là
c'est vraiment un moyen de transport
extrêmement d'archaïque comme vous
pouvez le voir ça gêne tout le monde et
il y à un nombre de places est limité
dans ses bois à l'intérieur on se met à
l'extérieur s'est défendu oui non moins
il s'est beaucoup moins chaud oui alors
c'est très pratique les tramways là bas
parce que le contrôleur ne passe pas on
paie un feu d'une façon extrêmement par
résiste bon alors si on est dehors on a
toutes les chances de ne pas passer vous
voyez ce viaduc c'est dommage en veulent
démolir
il relie e2 moreau le morro san antonio
et le morro de sainte-thérèse a je crois
qu'il est utile de vous dire que les
mots sont les collines dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure et qui sont
plantés oise air en plein milieu de la
ville elle-même lesparre et dans presque
chaque mort où est installée une favel
minh travel retail et c'est une sorte de
village de plancher de cartes un
bidonville même qui vous voulez une
agglomération taudis où vivent les gens
pauvres de rioz des noirs principalement
ce qu'était notre zone et ça seulement
c'est en plein centre et fait
particulier on dit que qui chante son
mal en chant alors ici en juillet et on
vit misérablement mais on chante 364
jours par an et en traitant la fameuse
grande nuit du carnaval car chaque savel
à son école de samba
mais qu'est-ce que d'une école de samba
bien écouter une école de samba les
compagnons de la chanson sont allés à
rioz et ont ramené une chanson qui je
crois infiniment mieux que je ne peux
faire va vous donner la réponse
cet amas
à l'école
et puis hatha yoga
me quitte pas
la gaieté leur fait oublier la misère
oui vous voyez ils sont même obligés il
n'y a aucun chemin et pas d'eau courante
pas d'électricité rien du tout ils sont
obligés de descendre en ville pour
chercher le lot dont ils ont besoin en
fait particulier je vous signale que
bien qu'il n'y a pas d'eau courante dans
les favelas ces gens sont d'une propreté
exemplaire il ou ils loin si loin de vie
enfin ça dépend plus le morro sur lequel
est construit la femme elle est aux opus
est lent il ya des gens qui sont trois
kilomètres à pied pâlir tout en montant
pour ramener l'eau chez eux mais
beaucoup d'entre eux dont ils seront
plusieurs rien s'ils vont plusieurs
voyages
oui bien entendu l horizon construite et
il ya des endroits où ils ont mis des
grands bacs pour recueillir loterie à la
saison des pluies mais malheureusement
pour eux la saison des prix n'est pas
très très long nous sommes ici dans une
des gares de banlieue qui s'est illustré
dernièrement d'une façon fort triste par
un terrible accident je ne sais pas si
vous vous souvenez il ya eu environ 120
morts et on se demande comment dans une
gare votre tiroir 120 morts et bien
l'explication la voix si c'est
exactement comme pour les tramways
c'est un pays vraiment
on n'aime pas tellement la discipline et
on aime bien prendre l'air oui surtout
grâce à wii en grappes et mêmes même
entre les tampons et extraordinaire aux
heures d'affluence il ya la même sur les
toits extrêmement dangereux il n'a pas
dit quand vous voyez ça n'a pas l'air
rien là même sur la locomotive imaginé
ça à la gare saint lazare
oui plutôt je crois oui ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur tes lauriers quand même oui
je crois parce qu'il est autant même si
ce n'est pas comme dans le tramway il
faut passer un portillon quand même pour
entrer dans la gare mais il ya
probablement des resquilleurs ça c'est
une sphère le dur
oui
et je vous avais dit tout à l'heure que
je ne vous parlerai pas du pain de sucre
et bien le voilà c'est vraiment très
difficile à rioz de ne pas parler il est
partout alors si vous voulez je vais
vous proposer un autre moyen de
transport qui va nous éviter de trop
parler de ce pain de sucre puisque et
tous deux trop le voir surtout puisque
nous allons aller sur lui oui ces moyens
de l'éviter si peut-être moins de
l'oublier un téléphérique en plein
centre de rio toujours c'est une des
rares villes dans laquelle se trouve un
téléphérique en place entre vous amène
en deux voyages au sommet du pam sur un
premier voyage qui vous amène d'abord
sur un morrow qui s'appelle l'amour de
requins et duquel on a une très jolie
vue nylon souvient le premier trajet
doit durer cinq minutes et le second 6
oui on a une vue très étendue sur le lab
et de botafogo quai dans l'horizon il
s'est par dont je me suis mais il fait
le voyage dessus comme ça jusqu'au oui
c'était vous allez bien c'est une manie
y en a dans les tramways il y en a dans
les chemins de fer alors je n'ose pas
vous répondre et si vous me posez la
question est ce qu'il a payé son billet
deuxième étape du morro deux cas tout à
fait à la gare au sommet du pain de
sucre
qui fait environ 400 mètres de hauteur
ce qui fait très haut vous voyez puisque
on compare carrément du niveau de la mer
non c'est faux nous sommes au dessus de
la végétation elle doit encerclé la
ville à la végétation encerclent
complètement la ville et même nous
sommes en ville vous voyez vous avez
remarqué tout à l'heure qu'il y avait
énormément il faut se battre
continuellement contre la forêt à gauche
vous avez copacabana alors là c'est une
probable aller visiter le pain de sucre
et la promenade favorite du touriste et
jacques auxiette extrêmement jolie et de
là on a une vue sur toute la sierra de
cariocas quai derrière et dont un des
sommets et très célèbre puisqu'il est le
fameux corcovado courrier de raison
entre les deux piliers avec le fameux
christ du reste si vous voulez nous
allons prendre un autre moyen de
transport pour aller voir le christ est
mort le christ
un moyen de transport un peu vieillot il
y avait ici de zurich chainel le chemin
de fer à crémaillère
alors là nous sommes toujours en ville
c'est on ne le dirait pas mais dès qu'on
a quitté les dernières maisons qui sont
auprès de ceux moreau on tombe carrément
encore dans la forêt et c'est vraiment
là la forêt vierge impressionnant
programme dans la forêt et sans arrêt
sans arrêt des ouvriers sont obligés de
travailler à dégager la voie parce qu'à
la saison des pluies les mauvais les
racines arrive à tordre les voies il est
dommage que vous n'entendiez pas le
bruit de ce chemin de fer à crémaillère
croyez moi c'est assourdissant oui pas
vraiment c'était très bon jeu mais aussi
dans a c'est vraiment merveilleux
vous voyez le soleil pénètre avec
difficulté tellement les arbres sans
grands noms c'est la gare d'arrivée nous
arrivons à environ 700 mètres d'altitude
un peu plus de 700 mètres d'altitude au
pied du fameux christ c'est un français
c'est un français c'est l'un d'eux qui
est très curieux du reste de penser que
en ce qui concerne la statue de la
liberté aujourd'hui en salles une
visiteurs et le christ du corcovado leaf
est apte à vide
oui décidément nous nous servons
vraiment beaucoup dans les pays
étrangers
et après quelques 300 marches on arrive
sur la fameuse terrasse ndour et à tour
sombre on voit la fameuse carte postale
il a plus belles baies du monde
et les touristes du reste on la connaît
tellement set beck en garde plutôt le
christ parce que comme il est très grand
et ans il a trente mètres de haut j'ai
pas pourquoi j'ai constaté que les gens
étaient plutôt tourné vers le christ que
vers la baie puis alors les souvenirs
bien entendu ça ne peut pas empêcher les
legends d'installer des boutiques de
souvenirs et vous qui avez beaucoup
voyagé est ce vraiment la plus belle
oui oui je crois vraiment c'est
extrêmement impressionnant c'est dommage
ça manque de premier plan
alors on a rit on ne réalise pas au
premier coup d'oeil vous voulez qu'on
siffle kit avions ainsi va nous amener à
l'aéroport de santos dumont ce fameux
brésilien parisien vous savez ce brave
santos dumont qui a inventé le ballon
dirigeable qu'il a fait circuler même
autour de la tour eiffel je crois que
c'est le premier il bien entendu les
gens de rioz comme il était d'oriola le
vénère profondément et en a donné son
nom au terrain d'aviation qui sert
uniquement celui là au l'hymne national
mais alors c'est là le problème au
brésil il y à 150 lignes nationales qui
sont exploités par 23 compagnies
différentes
il y a plus de circulation aérienne
entre rio et sao paulo que entre new
york et philadelphie par exemple je
crois qu'il ya 5 190 vols commerciaux
par semaine entre rio et sao paulo
c'est considérer c'est considérable oui
toutes les minutes et demie à peu près
un avion se pose où s'envolent de rios
et s'éteint le dernier moyen de
transport que j'ai trouvé arriola la
géologie soumises et bien mais si
minimum nous avoir éclairé sur les
transports de rillieux nous avoir montré
ses belles images
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de 10
bourguignon et de sallanches péters
montage claude richard sont jacques
sonar illustration sonore de nice désert
faux